one of the things we've been following
since the january 6th trump riots
has been the involvement of
law enforcement and or military in the
riots and we now are starting to see
numbers attached to this that are not
particularly
reassuring about the us military active
military personnel
and veterans are over represented
looking at the first 150
arrests and records released about what
took place on january 6th
uh cnn uh did an analysis of pentagon
records and court proceedings and
found that 14
of the first 150 arrests
are of current or former members of the
u.s military that's more than
double the proportion of service men and
women
in the population that's calculated
based on
census bureau and department of defense
statistics
back in 2018 there were 1.3 million
active duty members of the services and
18 million
veterans together that's 5.9
of the population and yet 14
of those arrested are members current or
former
of some branch of the u.s military uh
two of those are
army two are national guard of the 17
veterans six are former army eight or
former marines two or former navy one
was in the air force
at least one served in vietnam others
tended to be deployed
to afghanistan and iraq which makes
sense from the standpoint of
age at least one earned a purple heart
discharged at a variety of ranks and
included
officers as well a captain and a
lieutenant colonel
so there's a few different issues here
first of all
just from like a very abstract
historical standpoint if you're at all
familiar with roman history
there's sort of like a classic roman
historical idea
of disgruntled soldiers supporting
their leader their emperor for a coup
attempt and so
i don't know that we need to go the
whole sort of sort of poetic
uh route with this or or historical
analogies but they are certainly there
and it's not
an unprecedented thing one question i
have is
this particular study from pentagon data
done by cnn
is military current and former if we
were to say
military and law enforcement i wonder
where the number goes to from 14 that's
that's one question but this is a
well-known
sort of historical uh element that that
repeats itself and to be very clear
this isn't about saying troops are bad
as people
in principle there are i mean listen you
can even say that these are victims
right if you
understand the idea that there
is a massive adaptation problem
for people post-military service
this seems to be more of a vulnerability
when we talk to i mean i'm not making an
analogy here between
white supremacists and former members of
the military but what i do think is
important to understand
is that after traumatic experiences or
during them
people become vulnerable to really bad
ideas and to be sucked in by cults
uh and every former white supremacist
we've talked to
uh every former kkk person we've talked
to
has told us essentially the same story
about they were in a vulnerable place
and just as they fell for the community
granted to them by the ideas of white
supremacy
because that's what was going on around
them they could have been pulled in by a
religion
they could have been pulled in by by
almost anything and we know that there
are lots of folks who
uh serve in the military and they have
um a difficulty adapting to
post-military life
and you could fall into any number of
different things so this is not about
simply saying that the people are bad
people necessarily
uh but there might be some explanation
here as to why the trumpers thought that
if they do the insurrection
and they try to steal the election for
trump that maybe the military would
stand down is it possible because
they themselves as members of the
military current or former
thought that maybe that's something that
would happen that maybe the military
would join them in the insurrection i
don't know
uh i'm thinking out loud here but the
numbers are
are certainly stunning you know more
than a 2x representation
relative to the population of current
and former military
and um i don't i mean you tell me
whether this is too cynical
is it conceivable that they may have
been targeted on social media i mean we
know
at this point the degree to which
campaigns can be targeted to folks
so narrowly on social media is it
possible and i'm merely saying it's
something to look into
that there were uh campaigns
awareness campaigns about the riotous
insurrection
planned for january 6th that were
targeted to folks who for example
listed in their likes u.s marines u.s
navy air force or that listed in current
or former occupations
military it certainly can be done as far
as the technology is concerned
so then it just becomes a question as to
whether there was the volition
and the awareness to do it we don't yet
know all the answers but the early
numbers certainly are concerning if
nothing else